okay well Sue came Riley is it true that
you both went to band camp oh yeah sure
so what was what was band camp like
because you sounded like you enjoyed it
yeah oh my gosh we did we really enjoyed
it but it was you know we worked really
hard yeah
um a lot of us had never
done the things we were doing on the
show I had never sang I'd never played
guitar tsuki hadn't played you hadn't
played the keys
um you know the other band members had
either never played their instruments or
they hadn't in a while
um we spent a lot of time in that room
together do you do it now like obviously
you do but like do you play now outside
of it because now I don't know I imagine
when you learn something as an actor
like I anything you learn I've talked to
someone that learned how they had to
learn how to swim to like for their role
or whatever do you keep that up so I I
definitely like feel more confident
singing now so like if my husband sings
for example I'll sing with him yeah more
than I would have before
um the songs I know are just Daisy Jones
songs yeah
so tonight
like one of the better voices
she belts in this show she's really okay
[Laughter]
obviously we know Suki is a rock star
but in this show Riley has got I mean
her voice it's very it really does
remind me of like Stevie Nicks and it
has a Janice chocolate oh my God
way overselling I think you know what
though three singers you can kind of get
a textured tone in your mind so I know
that you you all love music you're you
actually tour you've released music you
do this in general yeah this is before
the film she's the real well he's like
living like she's acting cool right now
but she's like living a real rock star
life like right now like she was on tour
last Friday I know I just heard your
singing
was this inspired by being a part of
this but it feels like you've always
kind of done this yeah so I have been
writing music and putting out for a long
time yeah actually I think I think when
I started playing um Karen and then we
were at Sound City Studios and we were
making all this music and I think I got
it kind of inspired yeah kind of I've
kind of realized that I had to I was it
was now to you know make the make the
record and then we we stopped for the
pandemic so and I guess like being
around all these you know empowered
confident women I I was like it's time
to make the record that I want to make
and I didn't really realize that by the
time we put out the show I would have
done like 70 shows and two tours and
it's like very much yeah been happening
which is kind of it's kind of cool that
it's coinciding and you're playing this
character this year and then the sets
have to be incredible right they like
transport you like back to that time
that has to be inspiring as a musician
yeah yeah right I mean we we um I wasn't
in this scene which I was very jealous
about but you guys got to we we shut
down Sunset and which is like the first
time in 30 years they had shut it down
for production like a really big portion
of Sunset Boulevard where the Whiskey A
Go-Go and the Troubadour are we shut it
down and took over the street and put
old cars and kind of resurfaced the
outside of those old musics formed in
all those venues as days yeah yeah and
like kind of seeing it how it was back
then that was probably good it was
amazing I mean they did such a beautiful
job I think that was one of the most
sort of fun things about the show is the
World building and getting to be
transported back to the 70s yeah you
know you'd walk the great thing about
art yeah 100 I love that
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]